[Música]
é um prazer enorme estar aqui com vocês
vejam e quando me convidaram nem
convidado para falar sobre toxicidade
dançando um tema tomou do subjetivo é
aqui que é tóxico e eu resolvi falar pra
vocês sobre uma toxidade provavelmente
vocês conhecem bem mais nos traz o
strans uma palavrinha que já está entre
nós há umas dezenas de anos e os trans
traz presente uma um conjunto de
sensações muito características não é
uma sensação de que a gente é o tempo
inteiro correndo contra o tempo uma
sensação de que em função de estar
correndo contra o tempo a gente não dá
conta mais de tudo que a gente tem pra
fazer uma sobrecarga muito grande e essa
sobrecarga ela aumenta ainda mais a
nossa percepção social do stress e como
um bom ciclo
o contrário também é verdadeiro o strans
aumenta nossa sensação de que estamos
extremamente sobrecarregado em função
dessa sobrecarga a nossa maneira de
lidar com nosso trabalho também muda e
com isso a nossa percepção do nosso
tempo em função da mudança da nossa
produtividade seja percebida de fato ela
também muda e ela nos dá ainda mais ela
reforça ainda mais a sensação de que a
gente está correndo contra o relógio que
a gente está correndo contra o tempo e
isso aumenta ainda mais no nosso strans
isso então apresenta pra gente um
cenário está aí na nossa sociedade têm
contribuído bastante para aumentar
consideravelmente a quantidade de strass
que nós percebemos
nós vivemos nem o cenário tem sido
bastante ansioso gênico mas a pergunta
então ok ele está aí e daí por que eu
tenho que me preocupar com stress né com
que o estresse relaciona é dentro desse
contexto o stress pode se relacionar com
muitas coisas
os transportes relacionar com a
depressão por exemplo o stress pode se
relacionar com bananal to com a síndrome
de budd renault é uma espécie de
exaustão extrema em geral associada a
questões laborais é que nos trazem uma
sensação extremamente desagradável mão
estava de fato é muito desagradável
frente a mera idéia de fazer
determinadas questões do trabalho ou
mesmo ir ao trabalho nos traz também
está relacionado com a ansiedade e
definitivamente estresse está
relacionado com sistema mulher
ok então nós percebemos que o stress
está relacionado com uma série de
fatores é algumas patologias inclusive
que nós estamos de certa forma
familiarizados pelo menos no nome mas
por que a gente possa avançar um pouco
mais essa discussão é importante que a
gente entenda então o que é triste trás
e para que a gente possa entender o que
a estréia de fato é importante entender
é importante considerar que se trata de
uma resposta que tem componentes de
curto prazo e que têm componentes de
longo prazo
quando eu começo a tentar falar sobre a
resposta de curto prazo precisa entender
que essa resposta é nada por uma divisão
específica do sistema nervoso é o
sistema nervoso autônomo que lida com a
resposta do estresse no curto prazo como
o nome sugere é essa divisão se estava
nervoso até ela lida com questões que
são autónomas que nós não temos controle
evolutivo direito sobre elas
então essa divisão que lida com por
exemplo alterações de freqüências por
dia
com alterações freqüência respiratória e
com a maneira como nós controlamos os
nossos vasos sanguíneos fazendo com que
eventualmente a gente fique livre do
partido em função de uma situação de
outra
vocês podem perceber essas situações não
são ruins muito pelo contrário essas
situações fazem parte de um conjunto de
adaptações porque a gente lide com o dia
a dia com situações cotidianas
quero subir um lance de escadas é
preciso dessas adaptações
o problema é a partir do momento em que
essas situações começam a se fazer cada
vez mais presentes e mais presentes e
mais presente
eu ainda tenho que observar o componente
de longo prazo nas suas errado ao stress
é embora eu tenha semelhanças eu tenha
pontos em comum e estruturas
especificamente em comum com as áreas
que regula o estresse no curto prazo e
no longo prazo eu tenho outro tipo de
regulação
essa regulação ela vai ser
essencialmente nada por variações
hormonais
eu tenho muitos intermediários mas no
fim das contas eu vou ter uma variação
de um hormônio que hoje você já deve ter
de falar que o cortisol
essas alterações como o nome sugere
alterações longo prazo elas estão
associadas com alterações corporais
alterações em sistemas corporais que
lidam com situações de longo prazo por
exemplo o metabolismo energético então
por exemplo eu sou maratonista eu vou
participar de uma atividade de atividade
física ou que vai levar a algumas horas
dependendo do tipo de maratona
eu tenho que lidar e tem que modificar o
meu patrimônio energético para poder
lidar com essas variações
eu tenho que alterar o metabolismo dos
músculos eu tenho que alterar o
metabolismo dos meus ossos
essas são as alterações associadas ao
longo prazo
dessa forma nós percebemos que o stress
ele está associado a uma soma entre as
respostas de curto prazo e as respostas
de longo prazo mas essa soma não é
meramente a soma desses dois componentes
é uma só
organizada precisamente no tempo
nós podemos observar então que no
intervalo de segundos minutos
nós temos as alterações de curto prazo e
um intervalo que suplanta assim é e se
esses primeiros minutos nós começamos a
lidar com alterações de mais longo prazo
que vão se estender por horas porque nós
temos demandas e nós temos situações
diferentes no curto e no longo prazo
então por exemplo tem que dar um sprint
para poder pegar um doce que está saindo
do ponto então eu vou lá corro pegou o
ônibus está resolvido a curto prazo mas
eu tenho situações onde por exemplo sou
profissional sou um bombeiro eu tenho
uma situação de um deslizamento de terra
uma área extremamente instável eu tenho
vítimas precisam ser resgatadas mas que
a gente vai ter que fazer uma primeira
triagem da área de limpeza da área para
conseguir ter acesso e isso não vai se
resolver um par de minutos
isso vai demandar um conjunto maior de
tempo algumas horas eventualmente o meu
corpo lida com essas variações nas novas
grande problema não são essas alterações
mas a repetição e à cronificação dessa
resposta que é o que nós entendemos por
stress mas o que é interessante então a
resposta de custo quanto à resposta de
longo prazo é que há semelhanças muito
particulares entre elas no que diz
respeito a algumas etapas fundamentais
que tapa fundamentais são essas
a etapa de julgamento que essa etapa de
julgamento
a etapa de julgamento é essencialmente
um momento de processamento de avaliação
contextual onde eu entendo onde eu vou a
fazer uma avaliação se a pena é o noma
situação estressante
então eu por exemplo estou saindo da
universidade de algum lugar
em uma cidade perigosa numa situação no
bairro
enfim é outono uma rua parecida com essa
e vem com um enorme na minha geração o
rebanho desesperar e o cachorro ta vindo
e eu não tenho um muro não tem lugar
para responder o cachorro ta vendo ele
tá chegando
e agora quando ele está bem próximo de
mim eu consigo reconhecer esse animal eu
vejo que o cachorro do vizinho e que eu
cresci ele cresceu comigo desde a época
que ele ainda cabia na palma da minha
mão e que o máximo de violência que ele
tem contra mim tanto a cabeça ao clube
do meu orgulho
então isso representa esse ponto da
avaliação esse ponto do julgamento
frente a essa identificação aquela
situação ela deixa de ser estressante
fosse outro animal
a gente teria uma reação diferente e um
início de resposta diferente dessa forma
o julgamento significa pra gente é algo
maior do que o julgamento o julgamento
significa pra gente escolha significa
opção isso é fundamental
a partir do momento que nós entendemos
então que nós temos opções e escolhas
avaliativas
nós podemos começar a exercer suas
escolhas no trabalho
nós sabemos que nós temos profissões e
modelo de trabalho que são mais os seus
gênios que são mais estressante
então por exemplo som professor
professor primário processual
secundarista diversas turmas diversos
colégios provas para fazer provas para
corrigir aulas para montar sempre
correndo contra o tempo saiu de uma
escola levou para a outra uma das
profissões muito associadas com o jornal
de que o governo entende como é que eu
posso lidar com essa situação eu posso
mudar de emprego posso não mundo real eu
tenho conta pra pagar nem sempre o
cenário permite isso mas veja ainda
assim eu tenho opção eu posso tentar
focar já que é inevitável eu posso
tentar focar nos aspectos positivos
associados aquela profissão eu posso
tentar me deter sobre o quanto é
importante formar novos
cidadãos formar novos profissionais
participar da formação de crianças
adolescentes adultos em processo de
alfabetização
ao fazer isso a optar por focar em
aspectos específicos
eu minimiza a minha resposta de trás
aquele bombeiro estava numa situação
extremamente estressante de fato um
ambiente extremamente instável mas ele
pode tentar se deter na verdade aos
aspectos relacionados às vidas que ele
vai conseguir salvar
isso é uma opção muito relevante mas ela
não termina por aí
nós temos muitas outras opções nós temos
opções alimentares por exemplo nós
sabemos que alguns alimentos e alguns
componentes alimentares
eles se relacionam com a resposta do
stress então alguns agrotóxicos alguns
metais pesados
alguns conservantes aromatizantes que
sobretudo quando muito presente na
alimentação o acúmulo de lixo na
alimentação contribuem de maneira mais
direta mais indireta para o aumento da
resposta do estresse todo momento em que
nós votamos por uma alimentação um pouco
mais saudável nesse sentido evitando
sobretudo os alimentos ultra processados
os ladrões de micro-ondas em tempo
integral alimentação típica do
universitário
quando a gente tenta dar uma diminuída
minimizada nesse tipo de alimentação a
gente também está optando por uma vida
menos estressante uma vez que a gente
influencia a inclusive a produção dos
hormônios associados ao estresse e
eventualmente a própria resposta strans
ainda dentro das nossas opções
certamente uma das opções mais
negligenciadas que nós temos está
relacionada às atividades físicas
atividade física prática de atividade
física está associada a um conjunto
enorme de benefícios para a saúde e
benefícios fisiológicos a expansão de
apenas nas respostas traz a prática da
atividade física aeróbica ou anaeróbica
é treinadora o muito limitada essa
prática contribui para a diminuição da
produção de diversos hormônios da
resposta do stress e diminui ainda a
maneira como nós respondemos esses
hormônios
então mesmo produzindo os hormônios uma
vez confrontá los em situações de strans
nós respondemos a esse estresse de uma
maneira menos nociva - deletéria menos
negativa para o nosso corpo e o mais
interessante é que essas respostas
as respostas das escolhas alimentares e
as respostas das escolhas associadas aos
hormônios watch perfis não elas estão
associadas a áreas incomuns mas elas
lidam com alterações diferente o que
significa dizer que elas se somam mais
do que somar uma resposta a outra nós
temos uma atividade de energia está a
soma dessas duas opções é maior que a
soma aritmética meramente e nós não
terminamos por aí mas ainda temos outros
tipos de opções
nós temos opções sociais como assim
opções sociais
o estresse também uma resposta enfática
eu vejo uma situação estressante vivida
por uma outra pessoa eu também tem uma
alteração da minha resposta ao stress e
essa resposta que eu tenho resposta o
outro ela é tão grande quanto maior
proximidade que eu tiver com esse outro
todos nós conhecemos pessoas
extremamente tóxicas pessoas
extremamente ansiosas que estão prontas
para brigar com tudo e com todos num
outro contexto
se essas pessoas forem próximas será que
não seria interessante um convite para
que elas tivessem de alguma forma a
possibilidade de repensar suas atitudes
sobretudo com esse tipo de apresentação
de argumentos e se essas pessoas não
forem tão próximas assim se essas
pessoas forem mais distantes pergunta
será que eu preciso conviver com elas
será preciso conviver tanto será que não
possa limitar
venci com elas outro conjunto de de
opções bastante relevante eo resumo
disso é que sim nós temos escolhas
nós temos escolhas das mais variadas nós
temos escolhas laborais nós temos
escolhas associadas à nossa alimentação
à prática de atividade física nós temos
escolhas nas mais diversas e é por isso
que a pergunta que fica depois de todo
esse esclarecimento é qual é o tipo de
escolha que nós aqui estamos fazendo
para modificar a nossa resposta à
toxicidade social ea strans e por isso
que eu deixo vocês aqui e vou correndo
brincando de ser criança de novo que
essa é a minha resposta preferido strans
[Aplausos]